yes my name is a channel welcome back to
episode 43 of game programming so we are
back finally after that break that I
took for Christmas New Year's whatever
and first of all I want to wish you guys
a happy new year I hope you guys have
some big plans for 2013 I know I do and
hopefully you know it's going to be the
best year of my life basically and you
know I wish the same on to you all as
well now this show is going to resume
being daily now so um so yeah that's
something to look forward to I guess
nowadays actually an interesting day
it's 41 degrees right now in Melbourne
let's just say that okay and if you guys
are from America whatever you'll find
that it's actually 106 degrees
Fahrenheit so I mean it's kind of hot
right now so if I you know I didn't
sleep that well either so if I get
something wrong if I take a little
longer explaining something just you
know go easy on me and and yeah but
either way guys we've got some exciting
stuff coming up in this series I was
actually thinking about all the stuff
that we actually need to do going on in
this year and I'm hopeful you're not
going to be wrapping up this series this
year as well so yeah first of all though
if we launch our again that's always
what I like doing first we can see well
we're up to currently you can see that
we've got this this nice thing and we
actually talked about making a player
sprite and we did make a player's all
right on the player sprite a player on
class and we ended up making a player
class and you can see that all this
stuff if we're actually like um this
update method I'm fairly sure is
actually being used if I go into
references workspace oh oh it's not
being used huh oh well it's probably
being overwritten and then used I think
it should be used we're going to game
alright
all right cool so I'm you can see that
right now what we've got going on here
is these controls they're actually being
done in the update method now that's
incorrect because what it's doing is
something that it shouldn't be doing
we've got two integers over here and
what the camp what what is what actually
is going on here is it's adjusting these
integers right based on um what we hit I
guess a better way to explain this would
actually be if I go down and into this
render
method right here I'm just going to pull
up right on the right after the images
drawn cheat draw string and Industry now
all I'm going to draw is like the X um
and then you know plus X and then plus
also be Y so in other words I'm just
going to draw them some controllers two
integers integers on the screen I'll
also set the color to white and I'll you
guys don't really need a date sounds
trying to prove a point
now also the font to like I don't know a
bit down off and we'll give it like oops
like a 50 size or something
um whoops where am i doing all right 50
sighs and this obviously will pop
probably rounds the size of our screen
okay about 900 um probably popping it
around 450 by 400 or something all right
import font so if I again it's not in
the middle but anyway ah you can see
that as I move the as I move the
keyboard not only move the keyboard ad
so as I hit the different keys to move
our player or you know what seems like a
player you can see that what's happening
is it's basically keeping track of where
the player is in that sense right when
we start we're at zero zero and then as
we move is going to increase and
decrease this variable X variable if
we're moving horizontally for move
vertically is going to increase and
decrease the Y variable so that's kind
of what's going on right now so we just
get rid of all this stuff
I'll keep this here though just in case
I want to draw some other font things
alright so that's what's going on right
now now that's not technically correct
okay because all it is doing if we
actually check out this X variable is
being plugged into this level random
method and what it's actually doing is
it's offsetting the level based on this
scroll that is technically correct right
but it's it's not really like it's
working as you guys can see but it's
we're gonna run into tons of problems
including the fact that you know when we
have multiple players on the string on
the screen where we've got multiple
knobs to keep track of this is a very
bad way of doing it so what I'm going to
do right now is just delete that that's
gone and will also delete these X and y
variables now this stuff goes away and
this stuff sort of ends up throwing an
arrow that's alright um we'll deal with
that in a minute
first of all we need to actually create
the player so I'm going to go private
player player and what we've done here
is we've created a player object alright
we've officially credited player object
in the game class let's import the
player one thing we need to do is
instantiate it obviously currently
tickle it's equal to null that won't
work
I'm sure you guys are pretty comfortable
with object orientated programming
credit just before we create the level
actually we're proper credit after we
create the level so player equals new
player and the only parameters that we
would actually have like we've got the
spawn Pro
I'm going to hear which we want to deal
with now but what we don't have in the
player class is the actual um an input
sort of parameter right so I'm just
adjusting my microphone so if you can
hear that I am sorry we're not actually
inputting the input right what we need
to do over here is we need to give the
player a control method so I'm going to
try I want to type input handler input
right and I actually can call it in and
put how they call the keyboard so we'll
call a keyboard input right and and this
input that in the cable is basically
going to be an input method right here
now we'll also use the mouse in the
future but for now it's just keyboard so
let's import the keyboard and now we
need to also create a private variable
it's called keyboard again we'll call it
input and we'll just say that when the
class does get created let's make input
equal to keep this so input equals input
right and what's like what that's going
to do is set this parameter equal to
disk and or rather set that equal to the
parameter and we'll also do the same
thing for over here right so we'll also
put the keyboard input into here as well
so we've got um so that no matter how
the play is created it's always going to
have an input method so and this input
will actually be used over here to
adjust the X&Y ver it also will deal
with in a minute but over here we just
need to type in I think it's called
okay and now you'll find that we've
refer that we've created in it a new
player and we've got the key parameter
in there so that so that we get the UM
the keyboard basically so that we can
use the keyboard in this player class so
now we've done that let's actually
change the inputs of the play up so in
other words when we press the up arrow
and press it down our left right
whatever when we move our player when we
press the keys that we want to move our
player let's actually move her player if
we go all the way down to entity right
so in other words if we go to extends
mob here and then we click on entity
control click on entity will get will
get into entity class right and we have
two variables here x and y and
the X and y variables are the variables
that actually keep track of where our
mob or entity any entity actually but
where our entity is located on the map
so you can probably tell that if we want
to you know if if basically if input dot
no up is pressed if input dot up is
pressed right we sort of one on we want
to subtract from Y right to make it to
make it sort of go up if input dot down
all right we want to add to Y and exact
same thing for X so left and right we
want to do exactly the same thing except
for X so what we're doing here is if we
if we if we hold left button the left
arrow key or or the a button we're going
to subtract subtract from axial but
we're basically rewritten all that we
did in this update method but we've done
that we've done that in the player
method and then what's what is actually
doing is instead of affecting the in X
and in Y variables that we just created
in game it's actually going to effect if
we control click on this it's actually
going to affect the entities x and y
coordinates so it's actual location so
that in in other words in multiplayer
we'll be able to keep track of all those
locations and and it'll work out great
so yeah that's what we've done right now
we've added all these things into the
update method now few things that we
actually need to do first of all is run
this update method because if this
method is in being ran then it's not
going to be able to nothing's going to
happen as we press the keys it's not
going to do anything so we actually need
to go to player dot update right now
few things like straight away you can
see the mob has an update method and the
entity has an entity has an update
method the reason for now we're not
going to deal with that all right player
I like to sort of update the player by
itself just in case anything else goes
wrong the players still able to update
itself so for now we are going to do
that that way but otherwise you know we
don't even have like an entity system in
our level class yet so for now player to
update is going to work we might fix
that in the future depend
yawn if I feel like it or not and the
last thing that we'll do is probably
arguably one of the most important to
make this work again is this x and y
we're going to change it to Playa del X
and player dot Y all right just like
that and if we launch our game you'll
find that look at that our game is
working perfectly but what it's actually
doing here is instead of accessing um
this microphone you have to get a new
microphone stand this is ridiculous I
don't
oh I'm tightening in alright it's better
that's for falling I'm gonna order new
microphone stand this is getting really
annoying maybe like one of those desk
clip one anyway so G dot drawstring
again you know this is like the X now
plus XR no plus X plus play X now right
plus y plus player dot y and then we'll
draw it broader like 350 300 because 450
400 L and if we draw this right now then
you'll see that what we've got is it's
updating and like it was before but now
player is actually handling its own
movement player and mob and entity
whatever is handling its own movement
now this is one way to do it and
tomorrow going to cover the other way to
do it alright I sort of want to take
this that take this one step at a time
so you guys on ass at it but that is one
way to do it and tomorrow we're going to
take a look at another way to do it so I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
game programming what's quite a long one
and yeah hit the like button if you did
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye
you